وفي خبر ورد قبل قليل ايضا افاد مراسل
الجزيره بارتفاع حصيله سلسله الغارات
الجويه الاسرائيليه على منازل سكنيه في
مدينه رفح جنوبيه قطاع غزه الى 16 شهيدا
نرحب
بمراسلته اشرف ابو عمره ومن خان يونس
مراسل الجزيره اسماعيل ابو عمر اشرف ابدا
معك في دير البلح وعمليات الاستهداف في
المنطقه الوسطى لا تتوقف ضعنا في اخر
التفاصيل
نعم اخر التفاصيل هو وصول اعداد من
الشهداء قبل قليل هنا الى مستشفى شهداء
الاقصى في دير البلح ليرتفع عدد شهداء
المحافظه الوسطى خلال الساعات الماضيه الى
15 شهيدا وعدد كبير من الاصابات بعد قصف
منطقه مخيم البريج وسط قطاع غزه حيث اغارت
الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه على منزل
عائله ابو حجير وما زالت الطواقم تعمل
هناك للوصول الى ناجين او شهداء تحت انقاذ
البنايه التي تم اطلاق عليها عدد من
صواريخ الطائرات الحر الحربيه الاسرائيليه
اما في مخيم المغازي وسط القطاع ايضا
الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه قصفت منزلا
لعائله الحاج حيث هناك اعداد من المصابين
والشهداء وصلوا المستشفى سلسله غارات قويه
كانت خلال الساعات الماضيه قد شنتتها
الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه ونفذتها في
المحافظه الوسطى بالاضافه الى منزل في دير
البلح تم ارتقاء اثنين من الشهداء والد
وابنه في احد المنازل الذي تم اللجوء
اليها وهو احد النازحين من مدينه غزه في
منطقه شارع السلام وهي بنايه لعائله عبد
الجواد تم قصفها بالاضافه الى الزوارق
الحلبيه الاسرائيليه التي خلال الساعات
الماضيه كثفت من اطلاق قذائفها على الطريق
الساحلي في منطقه غرب منطقه الزوايده
وايضا غرب مخيم ل نصيرات وسط القطاع اما
المدفعيه الاسرائيليه بطبيعه الحال ما بين
الحين والاخر تقوم باطلاق عدد من قذائفها
واصوات انفجارات تسمع في ارجاء المحافظه
الوسطى من المناطق الشرقيه لدير البلح
وايضا المتاخمه لمنطقه شرق المصدر
بالاضافه اضافه الى شرق المخيم المغازي
وسط القطاع هذه الغارات الاسرائيليه حقيقه
يصحبها تحليق مكثف ومستمر لكل انواع
الطائرات الاحتلال انواع طائرات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي في اجواء المحافظه الوسطى بشكل
كامل ا ابقى معنا وفي خان
يونس اسماعيل كيف تبدو المعطيات والتطورات
الميدانيه لا يختلف الوضع عن 125 يوم من
الحرب الاسرائيليه على قطاع غزه المشهد
وذاته دائما الغارات مستمره القصف المدفعي
مستمر من قبل اليات الاحتلال وفي المحصله
دائما ارتقاء شهداء جدد نتيجه هذه الغارات
المكثفه والعنيفه التي تنفذها طيرات
الاحتلال الاضافه الى القصف المدفعي
واطلاق النار المستمر من قبل اليه
الاحتلال في محيط مستشفى ناصر بخانيونس
منذ صباح هذا اليوم سبعه شهداء في محافظه
خانيونس هؤلاء من وصلوا فعليا الى
مستشفيات المحافظه في حين ان هناك اخبار
وانباع عن اصابات في صفوف المواطنين
وشهداء في مناطق كثيره في المحافظه ظ
نتيجه غارات نفذتها طائرا الاحتلال
ومدفعيه الاحتلال صباح هذا اليوم في اكثر
من منطقه في الاجزاء الشماليه الجنوبيه
الشماليه الغربيه للمحافظه وكذلك الاجزاء
الجنوبيه الغربيه للمحافظه وكذلك المناطق
الشرقيه للمحافظه ويصعب على سيارات
الاسعاف الوصول الى هذه المناطق بفعل
احتدام عمليات القصف من قبل طيارات
الاحتلال وكذلك من قبل اليات الاحتلال
نتحدث بان الامر الابرز في خان يونس وهو
محاولات قوات الاحتلال ب عرقله وصول الناس
وكذلك الجرحى الى مستشفى ناصر في مخيم خال
يونس وبالتاكيد هناك محاولات حثيثه من قبل
المواطنين لنقل اصابات الى هذا المستشفى
الذي يتعرض لحصار كبير منذ اكثر من 15
يوما الحصار هذا على مستشفى ناصر اضافه
الى عمليات الحصار واليات الاحتلال
المتواجده بالقرب من هذا المستشفى تتم
عمليات اطلاق نار بين الحين والاخر قبل
ايام كانت قد استهدفت البوابه الشماليه
للمستشفى اليوم استهدفت اقسام المستشفى
بشكل مباشر حيث تعرض احد طواقم الطبيه
داخل قسم العمليات في مستشفى ناصر لاصابه
بعيار ناري من قناصه الاحتلال خاصه نتحدث
ب ان المستشفى ما زالت الظروف الانسانيه
والصحيه صعبه بداخله في ظل حديث متواتر من
قبل الطواقم الطبيه داخل المستشفى
بان امدادات الوقود في اي لحظه ممكن ان
تنتهي ويتم فقدها في مستشفى ناصر يعني
انقطاع التيار الكهربائي عن المستشفى ومما
يعرض حياه الجرحى وكذلك النازحين والذين
يقدرون ب 10000 نازح اضافه الى اكثر من
300 من الكوادر الطبيه موجودين داخل هذا
المستشفى
و450 جريح داخل هذا المستشفى معرضه حياته
من الخطر في ظل عدم قدره ايصال الامدادات
سواء امدادات الكهرباء امدادات الادويه
حتى وكذلك امدادات الغذاء الى من هم داخل
مستشفى ناصر الذي يتعرض لاطلاق نار اضافه
الى هذا المستشفى ايضا مستشفى الامل تابع
لجمعيه هلال الاحمر الفلسطيني هو بالتالي
ايضا يتعرض لحصار منذ 15 يوما بعد ان دخلت
قوات الاحتلال في محيط المستشفى وجرفت
ايضا جدران هذا المستشفى في الايام الاولى
من دخول قوات الاحتلال ما زالت قوات
الاحتلال في محيط هذا المستشفى وتطلق
النار بتجاه المستشفى وكذلك هناك حديث من
قبل اله الاحمر الفلسطيني وتحذيرات دائما
مستمره بضروره ايجاد حلول لهذه المستشفيات
حتى لا يتم تعريض من هم داخل هذه
المستشفيات للخطر من قبل قناص الاحتلال
وكذلك اليه الاحتلال اشرف او اسماعيل ابو
عمر من خان يونس
وايضا اشرف ابو عمرا من دير البلح شكرا
جزيلا
لكما